bonsoir mj de l g merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france emmanuel macron
donc et les présidents de cinq pays un
sahélien qui ont commencé à débattre
aujourd'hui des moyens de renforcer leur
coopération militaire et de mobiliser de
nouveaux alliés à titre personnel qu'est
ce que vous attendez professionnels
évidemment également qu'attendez-vous de
ce sommet moi j'attends des
clarifications
j'attends qu'on remette à plat la
présence française et surtout la
relation avec les pays concernés et
surtout qu'on puisse ouvrir encore
davantage des pays tiers la possibilité
de venir s'engager dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme parce que c'est la sphère
de tous ça n'est pas un pré carré
français ça n'est pas comme on l'entend
dire si elle a une nouvelle forme de
colonisation
absolument pas je crois que lutter
contre le terrorisme c'est la sphère de
tous les européens
c'est la sphère du monde alors on entend
que les russes seraient intéressés que
les américains se retirent
d'autres puissances étrangères
voudraient venir
qu'elles viennent et surtout aujourd'hui
on va mettre en place je crois à l'issue
de ce sommet la possibilité aussi de
financer de s'engager et puis surtout
d'avoir un réceptacle pour accueillir
toutes ses forces étrangères qui
voudraient s'engager dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme au sahel
sauf que vous le savez c'est pas l'avis
de tout le monde de nombreuses voix en
afrique demande tout simplement le
retrait de la france c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu emmanuel macron en préambule
de ce sommet a dit moi je veux des
réponses ce que notre présence est utile
il est ce qu'on a besoin de nous et ce
qu'on doit rester
vous les comprenez quand même ces voix
qui doute absolument il ya une
impatience qui voit le jour et on peut
le comprendre
un citoyen normal on y voit une
puissance avec une des armées les plus
puissantes du monde
patiner et ne pas réussir à s'en sortir
mais il faut il faut comprendre que vu
les distances vu la superficie vu les la
disproportion des forces et surtout la
complexité qui lie à lutter contre ces
formes de terrorisme là aujourd'hui
la france a à z nos amis de l'afrique et
du sahel à être plus stable mais elle ne
peut pas tout et il faut pour aussi
arrêter avec cette suspicion se sait ce
complotisme qu'on entend il faut
réaffirmer parce que ses revenus on a eu
des invités ici même des journalistes
africains qui nous aimer oui mais on
nous accuse les français de colonialisme
de son de voile à cette vieille
françafrique me répondez quoi
mais déjà nous dans
l'ambiance de ma circonscription où ça
mais moi je suis député du maghreb et de
l'afrique de l'ouest je suis très
souvent sur cette circonscription et je
l'entends 7 francophobie
cette haine de la france s'exprime est
de plus en plus monter cette ce
sentiment anti français
c'est ce qui exaspérait c'est sur le
maghreb et l'afrique de l'ouest
il entend vraiment monter mais la
meilleure des choses c'est d'abord la
comprendre de l'entendre et d'essayer
d'y répondre
la première des réponses et de
réaffirmer clairement les raisons pour
lesquelles nous sommes aujourd'hui
présents dans cette zone de l'afrique
quand on aura réaffirmer clairement et
que la volonté des états aura été
clairement exprimées et que la france
sera reçu un nouveau mandat dans le
cadre de sa présence et qu'on aura
réussi à aligner un peu toutes les
mêlées volonté tous les objectifs des
différents pays parce qu'il ya aussi ça
quand vous avez cinq pays qui eux-mêmes
ont des regards différents les uns sur
les autres et que vous venez pour
essayer de stabiliser toute la zone
c'est très très compliqué donc
aujourd'hui il faut réaligner tout le
monde essayait d'avoir des objectifs
communs et à loger 5 sahel qui monte en
puissance il faut le former le financer
on a des outils pour cela il ya beaucoup
de promesses de dons qui ont été fait
aujourd'hui moi je fais partie des
optimistes
je crois que la bataille militaire nous
allons la gagner
par contre dans 5 ans 10 ans en tout cas
nous la gagnerons vu les masses d'argent
qui vont être investis et vu la force
des puissances militaires en présences
nous gagnerons la bataille militaire
c'est une certitude
par contre il restera la bataille
culturelle
il restera la bataille de l'éducation et
restera la bataille du développement
et c'est là où je crois qu'on attend
aussi beaucoup de la france et la france
aujourd'hui elle
elle va se montrer elle doit se montrer
au rendez-vous pourquoi on attend de la
france au niveau culturel est ce que ce
n'est pas à l'afrique de gérer elle même
ça c'est ce que c'est ce que par exemple
nous avons fait j'étais à abidjan avec
le président de la république il ya deux
trois semaines le président de la
république a annoncé la fin du franc cfa
donc aujourd'hui la france ne battra
plus monnaies pour les états africains
de la zone du franc cfa et ils auront
ils ont leurs propres menée tous les
points qui sont aujourd'hui en litige ou
alors qu'ils donnent le sentiment de
cette forme de néo colonisation
demain il faut les prendre les uns après
les autres essayer d'y répondre que
c'est un grand malentendu parce que
c'est vrai qu'on entend aussi voilà les
français sont intéressés par les
ressources en uranium sur les terres il
ya ici un malentendu tout ça plus que
moi je pense que c'est plus qu'un
malentendu c'est une incompréhension et
moi quand je vois d'autres puissances
étrangères et la manière dont elles
elles investissent en afrique il n'ya
aucune valeur ajoutée pour les peuples
africains la france quand elle est
présente et que elle elle construit un
pont elle fait travailler des africains
et des africaines et des entreprises
africaines
aujourd'hui quand on voit d'autres
puissances notamment asiatiques qui
viennent et qui investissent et qu'il
n'y a aucune valeur ajoutée pour les
populations locales
maintenant voilà à à nous de faire en
sorte que ces fonds ne soient plus
construit par des puissances étrangères
et c'est là où il faut investir dans
l'éducation la formation pour que ce
soit les africains qui construisent
eux-mêmes leurs ponts ils construisent
eux-mêmes leurs universités leur école
et qui se prennent en main en donnant en
rendant les réserves de change pour
que les états africains plus battre leur
monnaie est créée ce qui ce qui est ce
qui a été annoncé
c'est à dire l'écho je crois que c'est
la plus belle des manières de dire
clairement
vous êtes vous êtes maître de votre
propre destin et la france hélas comme
un partenaire d'égal à égal est là pour
vous accompagner
ça va sans doute vous faire plaisir
parce qu'une alerte vient de tomber en
annonçant que la france et ces pays du
g7 vont effectivement renforcer leur
coopération militaire en qui jadis était
pas gagné parce qu'encore une fois en
préambule emmanuel macron a posé la
question de la présence française alors
que dans le même temps les états unis
annoncent vouloir réduire cette présence
d'ailleurs les présidents des pays
d'ussel souhaite la poursuite de l'appui
crucial des états unis il est
effectivement important cet appui est ce
que la france va s'en sortir ça parce
que dans le même temps donc la france
annonce ce renforcement de la
coopération et les etats-unis s'en vont
c'est fondamental aujourd'hui on a
besoin des états unis pour faire
décoller les drones on a besoin la
technologie américaines pour combattre
contre les djihadistes si les états unis
se retirent je vous avoue que même au
plus haut sommet de l'état on est très
inquiet et je suis pas certain que ça
aille dans le sens des intérêts des
américains parce que penser qu'en se
retirant d'afrique et que tout ça ne les
regarde pas je crois que l'histoire
récente nous a démontré que les
djihadistes les forces terroristes
pouvaient taper même sur le sol ibérique
c'est une tendance très américaine en ce
moment l'irad mon relais longs
rétropédaler mais enfin voilà la
tendance ne va pas
le maintien des troupes en syrie en irak
et là en afrique
c'est une grave erreur selon vous de
donald trump la meilleure manière de
répondre à l'irrationalité c'est d'être
rationnel pour deux la meilleure manière
de répondre à l'outrance c'est d'être
droit et respectueux pour deux voilà moi
je l'encouragé jeudi de manière un peu
disons désabusé que voilà le temps va
passer de nouvelles élections on se se
produire aux états unis nous verrons ce
que le peuple américain décidera mais
est finalement on s'en rend compte
les élections américaines concernent le
monde est donc maintenant il va falloir
que chacune et chacun d'entre nous
regardions de près ce qui se passe au
aux états unis parce que ça n'est plus
ça n'est plus possible d'avoir cette
manière un peu erratique de de ne pas
respecter 2-2 pas respectée dans ses
engagements de ne pas tenir sa parole
d'être dans la provocation quasi
quotidiennes voilà on a besoin d'un
monde apaisé d'un monde stable et moi je
j'encourage même à ce que l'on revoie je
me trouve aujourd'hui sur un plateau
télé particulier nous conviendrait à ce
que la france revoie aussi
ce qu'elle considère comme ses alliés
l'actualité en france dominée par les
retraites les syndicats divisés après le
retrait provisoire de la chp pivot
edouard philippe
l'annoncé samedi si les syndicats
réforme ils se disent plutôt satisfaits
les centrales opposé à l'ensemble de la
réforme des retraites appelle à
poursuivre le mouvement de grève hier
soir chez nos confrères de france 2
douar philippe averti nous allons aller
jusqu'au bout de la réforme le premier
ministre qui s'est dit déterminé à
équilibrer financièrement le régime les
retraites
il appelle les contestataires à prendre
leurs responsabilités et leurs traits de
l'âge pivot de la réforme un bon
compromis face aux demandes des
syndicats c'est l'avis de la porte
parole du gouvernement écoute et nous
avons considéré depuis le début que pour
mettre le régime à léquilibre c'était
avec une mesure d'âge en l'occurrence la
mise en place d'un âge à partir duquel
il y aurait un bonus et un malus de
manière progressive qu'on aurait les
meilleurs résultats pour les
travailleurs qui à partir de 2022 vont
avoir à 62 ans la possibilité de partir
à la retraite c'est une vraie avancée
c'est extrêmement important en termes de
justice sociale
vous êtes satisfait par les derniers
développements ce retrait de l'âge pivot
qui ne semble pas réglé la situation
absolument nous étions quelques
parlementaires a plaidé en ce sens tout
ce qui peut inquiéter nuire à la qualité
du dialogue et nous avons des syndicats
réformistes qui veulent aller dans le
sens de l'ue de la réforme et surtout
dans le d'ici 2025
on sait qui va y avoir 10 milliards
d'euros de déficit
le soit plus que le budget
de la justice le budget annuel de la
justice plus de 10 milliards donc ils
peuvent bien un moment donné falloir se
poser les questions et les questions de
réformer le système pour avoir un
système qui je pense peut être plus
juste plus plus égalitaire et surtout
permettre dans la responsabilité qui est
celle des décideurs politiques qui doit
être cédé décideurs politiques d'être
autofinancé aujourd'hui ça ne l'est pas
et je crois que nous devons absolument
parler avec ses syndicats et puis
essayer de trouver des issues
mais surtout écouter le peuple aussi
parce que même si on écoute on retire
tout un nom moi je pense que le si on
écoute le peuple quand vous regardez les
sondages d'opinion que les médias
mettent en ligne
on voit que ils veulent la forme et pas
n'importe quelle défense l'a un peu
dernièrement je devrais forme ils ne
veulent pas n'importe quelle réforme et
vol si vous dites et c'est pour ça que
c'est un peu compliqué c'est que quand
vous avez des gens qui manifestent avec
des intérêts totalement différents mais
qui manifestent contre c'est compliqué
de 2
de discuter parler quoi de la cgt exact
exactement par contre quand vous avez
des syndicats je crois qu'il ya des
syndicats réformistes qui veulent la
réforme
en tout cas quand vous avez des
représentants des salariés qui vous
disent nous voulons la réforme mais ne
voulons pas n'importe quelles réformes
et nous ne voulons pas d'aidé ou cases
et et donc nous voulons débattre et nous
voulons prendre cette réforme en main
donnons leur mettons leur fasse aussi à
leurs responsabilités
et moi je pense que effectivement il
fallait revenir sur sur sur l'âge pivot
nous avons été nombreux à le dire
maintenant que l'âge pivot n'est pas
émis de côté on peut enfin débattre de
l'essentiel c'est est ce qu'on a un
régime universel de retraite
est ce que les femmes vont pouvoir
bénéficier de la même retraite que les
hommes est ce que on va pouvoir avoir
une retraite qui soit financée voilà
maintenant rentrons dans le débat de
manière sereine et sans agiter à des
portes
moi je propose même une chose on le
cadre de ce débat puisque tout le monde
est inquiet sur la valeur du point
le monde le les français veulent une
réforme mais vous dise nous ne faisons
pas confiance à l'état vers cadre de
locations ne faisons pas confiance à
l'état parce qu'on le voit sur le point
d'indicé
parfois il est gelé plusieurs années et
cetera pour les fonctionnaires ils ont
raison et moi non plus je ne fais pas
confiance à l'état à ce qu'on appelle
bercy alors faisons une chose moi je
propose que dans le cadre du débat de la
réforme constitutionnelle qui arrive on
constitutionnalise en constitutionnalise
tout cela et on interdise est une règle
d'or qui interdit les déficits qui
interdit les déficits donc de voter des
lois en déficit
très bien maintenant faisons en sorte
que on introduisent dans le cadre d'un
nouveau pacte social
la possibilité pour chaque français qui
arrivent à la retraite d'avoir
d'interdire la baisse due
2 de sa pension voilà et
constitutionnalisant le donc et ce sera
un intouchable et une administration
quelle qu'elle soit ne pourra pas
revenir sur sur la valeur du point
donc voila moi j'ai dit phil protéger il
faut mettre en place un débat serein
apaisé
merci beaucoup m jid elles gardent
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france députés donc des français établis
hors de france merci à vous merci